I think the way people rush towards a
trend because they think that's where
the market is going is very dangerous
because it's incredibly unstable
information you can win a big client get
a promotion get a raise happy you know
do a good job produce something great
happy but that feeling dissipates I've
become very very interested in the idea
of playing in games that have no finish
lines need motivation what to top 10
with believe nation
he's simon Sinek and here's my take on
his top ten rules success vol 5 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't obsess with your competition
companies obsess about their competitors
which is fine tactically which is fine
for short-term but long-term most
companies aren't brought down by the
competition they know about they brought
down by the competition they don't know
about some new emerging technology you
know do you think the music business was
paying attention to the computer
business at all of course not they were
paying attention to other music
companies you know myspace wasn't
focused on friends to Facebook that
anymore Facebook existed but it's
Facebook that brought them down or
significantly hurt their business right
in other words if you don't even know
who your competitors are what's the
point of fixating and making all of your
business decisions based on competitors
all we're doing is reacting reacting
reacting this is why purpose matters it
gives us a North Star yes we have to
concern ourselves with our competition
from a tactical and short-term point of
view but to make long-term strategic
decisions based on a competitive set
that we don't even know if it's complete
based on technology that we don't even
know it's it's completely fully baked
it's madness it's absolutely madness
right so you want to fixate on the on
the on the path rule number two follow
your vision not trends what the leaders
of which so many gathered here today
what the leaders need to do to
understand the trends in their industry
better because it's very easy to say
this is where this business or this is
where does compensate this this market
is going it's actually that's what
everyone else is doing so how can you
get ahead of a trend in the way that
Steve Jobs was able to look at where the
puck is going so trend data's very
dangerous because all it does is report
a trend that doesn't report if it's
positive or negative and everyone else
has got it and everybody else has got it
so for example you know kids these days
are all using apps to do everything we
should make more apps but nobody says
it's healthy right in the 1980s you
needed to do cocaine to get through the
business day you know does that that's a
trend that's a trend you know cocaine
usage was up in the 1980s in businesses
if you work in investment bank you know
I was
right I was I was definitely not doing
that so the point is the point is it the
point is it's a trend yeah that doesn't
mean we should invest in it
right so trend data is I think the way
people rush towards a trend because they
think that's where the market is going
is very dangerous because it's
incredibly unstable information but you
have to as a leader anticipate where
your market is going and make three or
five year plans and the way you do it is
with vision right so for some reason
somebody keeps telling me that I just
might publish this at this to me that
I'm good at understanding the zeitgeist
and he's wrong I had no clue about what
people are thinking all I know is where
I want to go that's it as I said before
I have a vision of a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspired to go to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home fulfilled at the end of the day so
I can make certain guesses and
predictions about things I have to do to
get there rule number three be willing
to ask for help the biggest lesson I
learned was thank goodness I learned it
pretty early on which is and I think a
lot of business owners make this mistake
which is because I was the boss you know
in my own mind yeah I thought I had to
know all the answers
and if I didn't I thought I had to
pretend that I did and that's stupid
and what I learned is that just because
I may have the the top position in the
hierarchy I I'm not expected to know
everything and if I pretend to know
everything it diminishes the value of
all the great ideas and the great
intelligence around me and when things
got difficult I would never admit it
right I would just put on a brave face
and show up every day and and the the
the biggest lesson I learned was to say
I don't know I don't understand or I
need help at any level about any subject
yeah and amazingly I was always
surrounded by people who wanted a help
or who knew answers but they never
offered to help or offer the answers
because they didn't think I needed it
because I kept pretending that I knew it
all right not to mention the fact that
nobody likes a know-it-all so that was
huge for me and and when I was willing
to ask for help and accept it when it
was offered and and sort of accept the
humility of the fact that other people
know a lot more about a lot of things
than I know I know
one thing you know and they know lots of
things that's when things really started
to move because we were now a team like
we were actually working together rule
number four focus on the positives I see
a lot of questions here around dealing
with the negative team while dealing
with the team where we feel people may
not have the right intentions or the
right notice how do I do people work
with that the videos lost yeah it
happens and the answer is don't worry
about it like we can't obsess about the
ones that are doing something wrong we
obsess about the ones that are doing
something right instead of criticizing
the ones that are netic negative we want
to build up and compliment the ones that
are positive because when that's the
reward structure which is finding and
identifying and rewarding good then
everybody wants to be rewarded and
recognized and so eventually the
behavior comes in as opposed to
criticizing wrong nobody must be
criticized and all that doesn't make us
people back away and afraid so the point
is ignore the negativity and focus on
the positivity and start obsessing about
the people that are doing something
right I learned this lesson the hard way
I wrote a blog and we had a somebody
write in with a very aggressive sort of
note to me and sort of saying I'm a
hypocrite and all of this stuff and my
team got together and we discussed our
response and somebody wrote back and he
Rebecca a very nice response back we
thought okay how do we react to this and
I eventually got on the phone with him
and tried to talk with him and I talked
him off the shelf and talking about the
whole you knows okay and about six
months later I wrote another blog and he
wrote in others and we got together and
it occurred to us we're spending all of
this time with one negative person and
we were ignoring all of the people who
wrote in compliments and were supporting
our work and so he literally made the
decision that day that when we got
results like that we wouldn't care and
that if we were going to invest any time
of our people it was going to be to say
thank you to the people who were helping
us and helping compliment us and helping
advance the message and so we don't I
personally don't respond to those at all
anymore ever but I regularly call people
up to say thank you for helping advance
the call
and it feels nicer and this time better
spent and we're not wasting time anyway
so yeah focus on the positive also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below but I'm
interested in your opinion let's go
around the room it's too late the skill
to hold your opinions to yourself
and even though I'm gonna sell you the
most beautiful hammer I'm not gonna
guarantee the instructional integrity of
the house rule number five empower
individuals so with Steve Jobs playing
the fine art game because he was
crushing the competition or was he
playing the infinite game because he
just did his own thing so Jobs had a
very clear vision and it was to give the
individual the power to stand up to Big
Brother he was at his heart a rebel he
grew up in Northern California during
the Vietnam War which is the where the
beginning of the anti-establishment
revolution sort of start at him yeah and
that was his childhood and so he really
he really stood for the individual
standing up to to the man he had a big
spiritual side who's a yeah yeah and if
you look at the decisions he made he
made decisions like this here and
decisions through his vision before him
got to the interests right so there's a
very famous story of when he went to
Xerox PARC do you know this one so jobs
they just come off the success of the
Apple one and the Apple two it's already
a big company he's already well known
it's a it's he's already the darling of
business and their next big push is
gonna be into a technology they called
the Lisa that was their next computer
that they were gonna launch and just as
executives do they visit each other's
companies and jobs in a few of his
colleagues went to visit Xerox PARC and
Xerox showed them a new technology that
they had invented called the graphic
user interface right now remember Jobs
believed in the individual standing up
to Big Brother so the reason they made
their computers beautiful was not
arbitrary it's because if you had them
if they were pretty looking you put them
in the living room if they're ugly you
put them in the basement and you're more
likely to use something that's in the
living room than if it's in the basement
right the reason you make them simple is
because more people can then use them
and so when he saw this thing called a
graphic user interface he thought this
is a better technology it's a leapfrog
to make it easier for more individuals
to access the power of the personal
computer then what we have in the Lisa
so that's an infinite game because he's
thinking about what's right for the long
term rather than what his company and as
they left direct part Jub says we have
to invest in this and his colleague said
we're crazy we've invested millions of
dollars millions of man-hours already in
Lisa if we do this if we invest in this
we're gonna blow up our own company to
which jobs replied better we should blow
it up than someone else that decision
became the Mac the Macintosh that
decision was the Macintosh of which
remember Windows is an interface
designed to copy the Macintosh in other
words he completely changed the way
computers work to the point where now
any individual can easily use a computer
and he always made decisions that way he
made decisions always empowering the
individual so he was asked a question
about the movie industry cinemas and the
decline of cinemas and he replied that
the the cinemas were making the same
mistake the moving the stream was making
the same mistake that the music industry
made which is the munich music industry
falsely believed that their customer was
Tower Records and Virgin Megastore and
not the person who actually spent money
on buying the album he says you've
confused your customer with your
distribution channel rule number six
have a trusting team I was boarding a
flight and a scene played out in front
of me where one of the passengers
attempted to board the plane before
their group number was called and the
gate Adrian literally berated him sir
step aside I haven't called your group
please step aside and wait till I call
your group so I spoke up and said why do
you have to talk to us that way why
can't you talk to us like we're human
beings and she looked me in the eye and
said if I don't follow the rules I could
get in trouble or lose my job all she
revealed to me is that she doesn't feel
safe in her own company and her leaders
do not trust her to do the job for which
she's been trained to do and guess who
suffers us and the company
the reason we love flying Southwest
Airlines is because the company trust
them to do the job they would they've
been trained to do and they use
discretion we don't trust people to
follow the rules we trust people to know
when to break them and the problem is in
a fear-based society people fear for
their own jobs more than common sense
that was a perfectly a perfect scenario
of what happens when somebody in the
company is too afraid to break the rule
break the policy use discretion find
another way you know so almost
predictable that something will happen
something will break at some point rule
number seven find true joy how would
someone know if they're doing something
fooled there why how do you know oh you
can feel it you feel it you ever had
that experience where you feel like
something's wrong yeah you know sort of
you're like you make a decision but it
makes you uncomfortable you're not
you're not following through with your
cause or your purpose and you have that
ever have a decision where everybody's
like you're crazy because you're like
this just feels like the most natural
normal thing I could do I'm not even in
doubt here you know right now the
problem with simply running on gut is
it's not scalable this is the reason we
want to learn our why learn to
articulate and be able to speak our why
so that others can understand why we're
making the decisions were making because
the problem is if you only trust your
gut to those around you sometimes it
does appear that we're crazy or
unfocused and so people leave us and
don't help us because they think we're
does the minute we can articulate and
speak that why with clarity that others
can understand then not only will they
have context for the decisions we're
making but they'll rally to help us and
even do things that we didn't even ask
because they understand the higher
purpose that we're trying to advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer but
you can feel it and this is where joy
and fulfillment in our work come from
which is different from happiness you
can win a big client get a promotion get
a raise happy you know do a good job
produce something great happy but that
feeling dissipates it doesn't last for
you know it certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks right that that immensely
happy feeling that we will hide of that
big client we won or that big promotion
we got is now gone joy fulfillment which
doesn't mean that we love every day but
joy and fulfillment comes from that
feeling that every day our work is
contributing to something bigger and
that's that's way more important or at
least as important rule number eight run
your business by your values so the
infinite game exists up here the finite
game exists down here right the infinite
game this will includes the why what I
call our purpose cause or belief it's
the vision of the company it's where
we're going it's something that we will
never practically reach in our lifetimes
or ever but we will die trying that's
the point right
it's different from a big hairy
audacious goal which for all practical
purposes you could reach it may be
difficult but you could reach it
this is an ideal something it's a vision
of the world so my vision I imagine a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspire to go to work feel safe when
they're there and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day that is my vision
right
we will never practically get there but
we will die trying the United States was
founded with a document called the
Declaration of Independence in which the
document stated all men are created
equal now the United States has not
achieved that and will never achieve
that but it the country is at its best
when we're trying to achieve that civil
rights women's suffrage gay rights the
you know universal education universal
health care etc etc this is where our
values exists our values are timeless
they do not change every year whenever
we have a strategic off-site and if they
do you have a problem that happens in
big companies every few years a new CEO
comes in and they have a values thing
and they change and they change and they
change no no your values are your values
right and they're based on your founders
and they exist from patterns of how you
operate when you are operating at your
natural best when your company is
operating at its natural best when all
cylinders are firing when you're in the
flow whatever euphemism you want to use
there is a pattern that emerges and that
pattern are your values there's a
minimum of three there's no more than
five if there's more than five there's
usually redone
so you can find overlap that you can
find lowest common denominators and they
are intractable these things are
inherently intangible and hard to
measure right which is why they often
get brushed aside it's not that they
don't exist they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the finance what
I call the what it's all the tangible
stuff right things like our interests
exist down here because they are
tangible they are inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have the way you
build an infinite business is you want
to run all decisions first through your
values and your cause and then through
your interests that's how it works
rule number nine have infinite goals
I've become very very interested in the
idea of playing in games that have no
finish lines right
some games have finish line's right
baseball football right
getting apart is the finish line you
audition there's a beginning middle and
end who's rehearsal and practice
there's showing up for the audition and
you either win or you lose and then it's
over it's over right that is finite but
one's career is infinite there's there's
no end it's like our lives are finite
but life is infinite people come and
people go but life continues right
theater actors come and actors go but
theater continues it's infinite you
don't win theater you win a part but
what happens once you get the part
the finite game is over now you enter
the infinite game you have to be able to
convert right and the reason this is
important and I've seen this
unfortunately so many times from a young
age all you wanted to do was get to
Broadway and then you get to Broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there the immediate response is
depression
because I spent 15 years of my life for
this one thing and I got it and now I
don't know what to do next like what a
get to Broadway again doesn't have the
same ambition it doesn't have the same
passion you know that you've devoted you
from you know you're from Fargo North
Dakota and that's all you wanted to do
is get out of Fargo and make it to
Broadway and you may eat it right it
doesn't have the same kind of passion
and this is because these are finite
goals there's a lot of studies that have
been done with athletes who have finite
goals to become the greatest X in the
world right so Andre Agassi was one of
these one of these athletes he wanted to
become the greatest tennis player that
ever lived
guess what everyone in his life he would
he would view them through how do you
help me get to that everything was how
does this help me get to that everything
was a transaction to how do you help me
move to there and then you know what
happens he achieved it he became the
greatest tennis player in the world and
you know what happened immediately after
depression Michael Phelps set out to
become the most medaled Olympian in
history do you know what he achieved it
you're not happened to immediately after
depression they spend their whole life
working for one goal though most will
never get it the few that do don't know
what to do next because their goals were
finite their goals were finite right and
so there are finite components to your
career but your career should be
infinite so yes of course you have to
win the finite game you have to get the
part but immediately when you get the
part
now you convert to infinite and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be a courageous
leader in military we're willing to
sacrifice ourselves for the gain of
others right but in business we're
willing to sacrifice others for our own
game yes how do you build that military
mindset in companies like here or other
companies leadership I mean it's it's
leadership creates an environment and
it's I mean this is what I learned the
the the the whole concept of leaders
you'd last and those lessons that I
from spending time with folks in uniform
it was born out of my own experience
where I was going through a point of my
career as my career was growing all of a
sudden you have new friends that I
didn't have before and and that's
wonderful and then I learned the hard
way that they weren't my friends they
were playing me they wanted access or a
deal or something right and I and I I
learned it the hard way
and so I retreated I was like I wanted
to be friends with nobody else but the
people I knew way back when which is
also not a good way to live and yet
simultaneously I'm spending time with
tons of folks in the military who you
know in business we have colleagues and
co-workers in the military of brothers
and sisters and that's a different kind
of relationship and as you know I have
hugged more people in uniform than I've
ever hugged in suits I've cried with
more people in uniform than I've ever
cried with in suits I've stood in the
audience and listened to officers give
talks and I've sat in the audience and
cried I've never cried it with any CEO
game yet gave a speech ever right so
there's a different nature of
relationship and my original conclusion
was they're better people that the
reason you get a disproportionate amount
of these kinds of behaviors is because
they're better people and better people
are drawn to a life of service in the
military which is why and we find a
disproportionately high number of them
there and the more I started to learn
the more I realized I was completely
wrong it's the environment it's the
environment and when the leader creates
an environment in which people feel that
someone has my back they will do
extraordinary things and what I learned
is that courage is not this deep down
internal fortitude right
it comes externally it's like a trapeze
artist would never try a brand new
death-defying act unless they had a net
the courage didn't come from the trapeze
artists the courage came from the net
and it's the same in the military which
is especially when you're in
life-and-death situations when you're
when you're when you're in theater you
people who you don't like you still rely
on to save your life and the reason that
works is because you don't have to look
behind your shoulder and that mentality
and you know better than anybody which
is when you when you are deployed into
dangerous places nobody sort of loves
deployment but people have warm feelings
towards deployment which is really
strange and suicides rarely happen in in
combat situations they usually happen
back home and it's the intensity of the
relationships that create that warmth
and the sort of weird enjoyment of
really bad uncomfortable and dangerous
circumstances it's because there's we're
human beings and human beings as social
animals feel our safest when we trust
each other and good leaders are capable
of producing that so great businesses
look very much like well-run military
organizations you know there's poorly
run military organizations as well but
great businesses look exactly the same
where the leaders give the glory they
distribute Authority they push it down
the ranks let people make decisions if
they screw up there's no risk of getting
fired if the company misses it's
arbitrary projections on its arbitrary
date we do not use the people to balance
the books we figure out other ways or we
even invite the people to help solve the
problems these are the things that
produce that circle of safety that
produces the exact same outcome where
people will love each other cry for each
other sacrifice for each other you see
it in business plenty but it always
boils down to leadership now I've got a
special bonus clip from Simon on how to
embody female leadership that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions you watched a video now it's
time to take action here we go question
number one where do you need to be more
courageous in your business number two
who are you going to ask for help from
and number three what's the core value
that you want to run your business by
it's not that we need more female
leaders it's that we need more leaders
to act like females women just happen to
be better at done you know traditionally
male characteristics like aggression or
decisiveness is only one part of
leadership but there are traditionally
feminine or female characteristics like
patience like caring like
per maternal instinct you know that are
extremely important if not essential to
good leadership
so the problem in America today if not
the world is we have lopsided leadership
we've over we put too much emphasis on
male leadership and we need to balance
it off and the best leaders whether
they're male or female embody patience
and calm and reserved and and caring and
that motherly instinct or fatherly
instinct like you know that that
parenting instinct and so we need it
more balanced oh absolutely we need more
more female leaders but we need them to
act like females we don't want them to
act like men I don't want women who are
decisive and aggressive I want women who
are caring and patient and all of that
good stuff
I want men like that too so yes we
definitely need more female leadership
whether that's definite
if you want more Simon Sinai check out
the other top 10 rules video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there they know
exactly what they want they can see the
summit what they can't see is the
mountain people put harley-davidson
logos on their body to say something
about who they are corporate logo